hello and welcome to this video this is
coverage of game eight of the World
Championship match between the reigning
world champion magnus carlsen and the
Challenger Sega kayaking yeah i'm
recording this video relatively late so
i probably I'm not spoiling things yeah
so I'm probably most of you will know
the result and know that this is a
crucial game for this match let's get
going we have seven drawers in the books
before this game so it's tied and any
decisive game um will have an enormous
impact on the match so d for by cars and
s you played in the first game however
we don't get a trump yeah popski again
but rather 9003 after which ki can plate
the move d5 and a slight change to what
he usually does I mean it's not a big
deal but usually he starts with e cigs
and keep the option open to play the
Queen's Indian this is what he played
for example successfully in the
candidates tournament on d5 basically
says okay I'm going to play a Queens
gambit em what line precisely is not not
so obvious and probably it would have
played a six but it's just speculation
yeah he would have played he implies
that Carlton did not go see for he
actually played the movie III
interesting this is the courier opening
or college system and it's a pretty rare
guest at the high level um I problem I I
didn't look it up but probably this was
last played on this in a world
championship match maybe in the in the
19th century that's actually likely so
what is why the idea why does developing
the kingside quite quickly can castle
basically in two moves and yeah we play
let's play this except for kayaking
did we should be three c5b three this is
the development plan that wide usually
is out to to get if you're carrying this
Bishop this Bishop is on d3 and there's
a good lineup here looking at those
diagonal so quite often white wants to
play quite aggressively with a setup
it's just it looks pretty modest but
there are actually some ambitious ideas
connected to to it and by the way is six
of course here is not the only move
black can also play and all kinds of
stuff I looked at this with black ones I
me know it's not the most critical
opening but I looked at it and I
concluded that I like c5 this is a
pretty aggressive try but I think it's
one of the ways to punish white player
who plays unambitious li fe sewing
clients so this is my recommendation by
the way if you if you want one of course
is six is what ki can play this is a
good move as well c5 g3 Bishop e7 yeah
all this looks perfectly logical now be
six played by the Challenger normally
people start with 96 but b6 is of course
a good move it hints at the possibility
of maybe playing Bishop to a 6 in some
situations and generally be more
flexible the accountant now played d
take c5 and with this move we leave um
yeah a commonly known a theory he could
have stayed within normal grounds with
the move like c4 which introduces this
very um a very tense situation in the
center we know that we see that it's
fairly symmetrical but why it has a
slightly more active bishop 23 this is a
also a very valid choice he took on c5
forever and kayaking took with the
bishop this is a very typical decision
for kayaking strategy in this match he
also could have played the pawn
recapture
while being objectively probably equally
good as Bishop c5 it gets more attention
in the position it's just more yeah it's
not symmetrical very likely black will
get hanging pawns and this is a bit too
sharp for the changes tasty wants to
play as solid as possible at Bishop c5
is the more solid move in terms of pawn
structure so all those moves I think
seem fairly normal the night comes to
dissemble I think it is better place
than on c6 c5 can be a good square for
this piece the accountant not played see
form I think this is the problem most
obvious way of playing he should
certainly attack the center somehow and
before instead I think was yeah [ __ ]
named because black can easily trade on
all the pieces him now i'm not sure
Knight f6 or something like that this
general pawn structure amid white will
go back this pawn structure in general
is quite well known from many openings
most notably the Rubenstein French and
usually if Black gets some pieces traded
like here he traded the light squared
Bishop he's totally fine so this is a
very much harmless OC form probably
better here and kayaking 2.0 at first I
thought oh my god it's why does he have
to play in such a symmetric away all the
time like taking the first opportunity
to make this a completely symmetrical
structure and however there is some
point to it because black doesn't really
have such a great waiting move if white
takes let's say black plays a move like
that and after the capture it's not so
clear if black has a good recapture you
don't necessarily want to take with the
night as since 94 coming and then you
have to move the bishop
probably if you don't want to give it up
and this isn't all that great and you
get the same structure after all so
probably taking it's not a bad choice by
the Challenger also objectively speaking
a good Jewish was ok night takes make
sense here the night looks at those
squares Queen seven connecting books
then we see the pawn structure is
completely symmetrical the only
difference is with the piece activity
where white is a little bit ahead but
just a little bit I'm a three trying to
play before and this is just stopped
yeah it should be played a five is a
good move and should be played a five so
Knight d4 but cards not the most obvious
mover a thought but ok well me if there
is some kind of holy em and if you get
to be five maybe you can use these six
however we should note that he is yeah
moving pieces away from the King side
and this is something that gets to be
important and rook the eight yeah I
guess looks kind of like a normal move
black definitely does not want to kick
this night this is so seems wrong as the
night gets a good square here or
potentially even here even though I like
95 am I mean the night here let's say
I'm the queen will move and now why does
supporting this I think white is a bit
more comfortable in this position again
it's symmetrical but there's a little
bit more activity here for white than
there is for black it's nothing special
but there is little reason for black to
invite an i-gaf five so Luke the ADA's
is perfectly fine move rooty one oops
eight foxy one so all this looks
completely natural and yeah now what
should a kayaking plane and again I
don't I think sudden moves like a five
and a good player normally just discard
them it just invites a piece
that cannot really help black in any way
in this case by the way there is some
tactics er do which night does it make a
difference probably not like this tactic
notice there's this tactic going on I
wonder if this is actually interesting
because this Bishop c4 stuff I eat you
can actually take first okay and then
take this is actually better now we have
this thread in addition to the whole
problem that black has lost the bishop
am yeah well he high versus it's
nonsense anyway I don't think this is a
move that it's considered very long by a
strong player yeah he played 9 f8 I mean
make sense they're opening up C and D
file and potentially bring the night to
g6 yeah an interesting moment now cause
a place to move Queen to you one and I
have to say that this probably would
would not have been on my list of moves
simply because um yeah I don't quite
comprehend what it is doing in some way
I mean maybe Bishop f1 is prepared and
in some cases you might have before
throw the support but I still don't
quite see the the huge benefit of the
month the position m is equal ish anyway
we have a symmetrical situation C and D
file are open the only thing that you
can argue is the set is neither somewhat
active and b6 is slightly weak but this
is not something that should be of any
importance yeah 96 bishop f1 we already
discussed that this was one idea and now
night you fall played by the challenge
again active with a night yeah and our
next move by causing this is an
indicator the neck
smooth office mindset in some way
because night b5 is a really risky move
and why is this a risky move the the
reason is the night is getting to this
square on b5 which is pretty far away
from the King side if you look at the
board and make it divides like in the
middle of the board here like this is
the inside yeah and here we have the
Queen side I know basic yeah but still
if we do if you look at that on the
Kings side black has more pieces than
White House and yes the two nights and
now there is a move that would be very
interesting Queen g5 with this the Queen
also gets into into an aggressive stance
here so we have two nights the Queen the
bishop and this Bishop all get towards
White's King so black has a local
superiority on the Kings side and those
situations are always risky if one side
has more pieces against the king then
the other side has to defend white only
has Queen and Bishop to defend here and
those two nights they are off side this
is the bishop in terms of a defensive
role and a very tricky situation
kayaking could have played is more cream
g5 and now there are there are a couple
of possibilities that all feel dangerous
for example age 3 is a move to kick this
away like you can go here and
immediately side with a threat and hear
the engines already confirmed that white
is absolutely obliged to take only five
it's not possible to to avoid this this
capture and if this is the case mmm
what's position is not good I mean what
else this is supposed to play
let's say it's a just just for
argument's sake you play some kind of
King move oops yeah this ed white cannot
take this and now will loose material
like this is this leg is an exchange up
this is a thread anyway so what is why
it's supposed to do again the bishop has
to probably take the night and here
black is very comfortable it's a
position that white maybe should hold
due to the symmetrical nature I got to
deform but it's not fun only black can
be better it's not clear what Carson
intended after 3g5 because there is no
really great option for white yeah it
was not played kayaking after some
consideration played Bishop to c6 so he
is absolutely keen on keeping things
simple and somewhat manageable he does
not really want to get into any risks
this however is a situation where
frankly I don't swim see any risk Black
is just attacking with Queen g5 so good
question but i think this decision a4
played by calvin and now Bishop to b5
yeah this is some blocking the D file
and potentially intending to take the
c-4 night the position here I think is
still roughly equal but Castle is really
an intent of trying something that's a
weird sentence he really intends to do
something even though there's nothing
really going on it's taken on c4 him
kayaking is just eliminating this night
because it is a is an annoying piece
it's not very dogmatic giving up the
pair of bishops because this will be
traded as well as happened here takes
root cheeks and now kayaking took on c4
just simplifying
and keeping the potato keeping the
position equal yeah and now we come to a
pretty amazing decision for me at least
i would think here for probably like
half a minute and then take on c4 with
the rook and I wouldn't even consider
the move that he played and cousin out
took with the pawn and was is weakening
now its own porn structure on the
queenside a very surprising decision I'm
after the standard move the position is
probably roughly equal you can argue
then white maybe has a slight pool
because of those porns that are rather
weak yeah not like they drop immediately
but at least there are some some kind of
weakness that one can play against we
really have to take note of that because
here he takes a strategic risk with the
beep on capture where it was not
necessary it is not like the alternative
was bad for him so he is willingly
weakening his position to get some
dynamic play and the dynamic play is the
following the D file black now
definitely does not want to take yeah in
case of a capture White's pawn structure
all of a sudden gets repaired and the
move c5 will prove to be dangerous
because the Queen looks at a five so
just an theoretically speaking let's say
I'm black plays a move here something
like that and white play c5 this kind of
situation is awkward because white will
get a strong a porn supported by the
bishop that's not desirable s'okay i can
move the rook away so what did council
get for his bad pawn structure he got
the d file so he traded some aesthetic
that's a problem on c4 for dynamic play
on the on the file g3 to get the bishop
activated this is this makes lots of
sense
and now aged six by collecting note that
ki can plays a good game a place in a
very solid very sensible way making know
a little bit of look for the king so
there's no background check made anymore
and so this position is probably roughly
equal and the next move is very clearly
showing what what Magnus is after he
plays f4 here again this is a very risky
move long-term it's all long-term
because white weakens his King
considerably of course he gets a dynamic
compensation for this it's not
objectively bad if you ask your computer
it will say 0 and it was zero before and
0 after the smooth but this is not the
point for a human player this move is
quite risky because your king will never
be in safety again with white plus note
weaknesses like this like III so what is
really pushing forward to get something
get something going 9 a-7 it was a clear
idea of this after dislodging the night
you get the success to the c6 square
kayak in places where queen a3 looking
at this pawn so that black has
counterplay note that in this position
Carlton has the opportunity to take on
b7 I think this pretty much would have
poured the plaque here in terms of any
winning ideas for black because after
this series of catalyst why it is
extremely active they have the Queen and
tonight here are very active and it
makes it very difficult for black to
ever get the rook activated and this is
the thing without the rook black will
not win this game if he somehow would be
able to enter with the rook it would be
a different story then probably white
skin would be in danger but that's not
going to happen anytime soon yeah here
here black line actually if he likes
take another porn but yeah white will
put the bishop here and the 936
Bishop sorry the rope on mp8 is just a
bad piece and will ultimately probably
stay on f8 for the time being
materialize black is fine but you cannot
use this material all that well the
likelihood of the drawing a thing is
very high some kind of situation where
both sides cannot make any progress
invest it was a safe choice actually to
take on this seven but this is not a
game of safe choices 96 was played by
thousand and now we have eight of course
that was hanging and here h3 again
showing what is after he wants to secure
the King on age two and then just a tick
in the center ideas arm infiltration on
d6 or d 8 or pushing the e porn all the
way forward this is definitely not
harmless what why does after here
absolutely not so we have to also note
that both sides didn't have all that
much time left i'm not sure i curate the
clocks ah here they are roughly okay but
they are not precise 22 to the second
and yeah h 395 playback hijacking that's
a good move because taking here would
have been risky due to queen bee to SC 5
now is a substantial threat yeah and the
night move here gives away upon so good
play here by the Chandra 95 activating
and I could take a forward another the
idea King H to make this King save 90s
Andrew create and now we see ya White is
invading and has quite substantial
activity for other for the pawn and the
Black Knight is currently not doing all
that much and white is is extremely
active and yeah a g6 now played by kayak
a disease again a very sensible move and
move that I think um yeah I like here
and it is an interesting position where
if you look at look at the
and just blindly kind of accept what it
says and get a wrong perception here
though the computer points out now the
good move that Carlton could have played
but was not very human in a way one way
you played Queen before attacking the
knight a very human very direct move the
computer suggests 95 and this is indeed
strong if you look at this a little bit
closer and you'll recognize that black
has some coordination issues a key point
and this is what makes the move very
difficult for human somehow is to
actually put the route back and put it
on these six so if black goes back for
defense this move it's quite annoying
it's difficult for black to meet and
there are all kinds of ideas queen bee
496 sometimes g45 the right moment not
easy at all the computer gives white
full compensation here and it is a
difficult position from black to play
this would have been a good
justification of whites playing cards
effect win before however I still think
he's probably all right I mean he sees
taken enormous risks by giving up the a
porn and going for the for the activity
but he is active enough I think and
interesting now I let me place them very
very cold blind of kings.seven stepping
into the pin and alternatives weren't
all that great yeah what did I look it
rook g8 yeah just taking clack is a
possibility just to keep it simple
something back then was possible with a
likely outcome of a draw the night is
extremely active and together with the
Queen keeps black Pierre pieces passive
95 was a strong choice but this is a
very difficult
move to play for a human player 24 is
much more natural I think the clock
times are roughly okay here with two
minutes for cards and four for kayaking
yeah King g7 a cold-blooded move and now
we come to a key moment of this game and
in some way also of the match and Carver
still can retain a good compensation
here for his pawn and by playing either
Knight to e5 or look to the seven look
to the seven is a bit of a computer ish
move but it certainly makes some sense
f10 wants you look into it a little bit
yeah the rook is not bad here on that
that seventh rank these dis moves would
have retained compensation but what he
played now is rather shocking but it's
kind of you know this is move 35 he's
got two minutes and he sees a technical
opportunity the move c5 there are some
technical lines now that look excellent
for white and hasn't happen to it
happened that cards overlooked a certain
replying by black first of all c5 why is
that even move in the first place m well
some things don't work yeah you cannot
take with this plan us the night you
cannot easily take with the pawn that's
Queen d6s strong yeah this is actually
winning for white because the move Queen
e7 and collapses is impossible to
prevent well this is not trivial I mean
cars and saw all those ideas but there's
one defense that black hairs and that
was found by the Challenger I actually
believe that this is not that tough to
find but it's a it's a matter of yeah
there are different opinions on things
like that because personally here I
would check this move first young get
rid of the attacking rook that's what
happened Knight takes and now taking
with the night also would be the first
thing that I check once I spot
that the Queen enters it's not trivial I
mean don't get me wrong it's not trivial
at all but but still okay night ticks
and queen to d6 that was causes idea the
night is attacking f7 and if the Queen
joints this is tough to defend yeah okay
here kayaking is down to roughly two
minutes and it's extremely extremely
sharp and double dashed not the next
month will be of huge importance and he
mainly has to lose I mean the thing is I
just read a post on on reddit a couple
of minutes ago was started the recording
of the video where they say that Queen
a4 is a computer ish move sorry I mean
this is just a normal move you see Queen
e7 as the threat I mean this is easy to
see him because what else is the threat
may be Queen c7 but then the 97 would
stop it so Queenie 7 is easily
identifiable as a threat and that leaves
you actually with the black pieces that
leaves you with two candidate milles 23
and 24 to go to the seven in both cases
just them or allowed us and queen a four
wins the game and Queen d3 what kayak
and play it does not win the game so I
don't think that was particularly tricky
to spot that 24 is a move what is
possible however is to overlook what he
overlooked and he actually said that he
didn't overlook night exact said that he
actually expected the move but I have a
bit of a hard time to believe that any
actually but ok and we have to give them
the benefit of the doubt of the press
conferences and okay 96 that's a funny
funny reply we should look at Queen a 40
and to see what what's going on Queenie
7 is easily stopped that's just
absolutely nothing so
queen bee 619 now what Queen goes
somewhere I don't know where this it
doesn't really matter or that much
blackwell just put the pawn in motion
and will very likely win the game
without any big effort like here and
then a 433 the black king is safe here
there's nothing nothing really going on
yeah but she played Queen d3 and this
has this funny reply light takes in six
yeah a nice a nice little tactic black
cannot take and plunder the Queen and if
you move the king there's this funny
clack clack with perpetual very nice
yeah so player can has no choice he has
to take it with a pawn and now change in
yourself that's the point all of a
sudden white is breaking through with
the Queen a scenario that during it did
look quite quite unlikely so what
happened to you will see 5 Carlton was
really putting the utmost pressure on
like yeah thing the most aggressive move
he had overlooked that black had a
winning continuation but kayaking didn't
take this opportunity and now we arrived
into this position here and it's not
easy this position Black is a pawn up
five against four and has those passes
here on the queenside that are extremely
important the main thing however is that
the black king is very insecure and all
those pawns are weakish and the white
queen is near the king yeah black played
a form with the final move on the father
or this is the final for the time
control and now he for being played
kayaking set then when you played
through you three that you saw the so
the whole sequence but overlooked that
white can play you for yeah maybe it's
really how it was but um yeah I just
feel that it's pretty unlikely to not
consider Queen 84 if you see Queen d3
that white can take on
six why don't you just look quickly if
you have a good alternative it's clear
that the Queen has has to help otherwise
you cannot defend the pawn anyway
benefit of the doubt I think is the word
and yeah II form after you form this
diagonal is broken so g6 the same was
checked all of a sudden Carlton gets
very serious play against the king they
are Queen d7 played by the Challenger a
good move i think the Queen has to come
back and help in the defense this is
clearly making sense cat takes Queen g7
yeah and now create Queen f8 now Queen
g6 would invite a repetition quite
clearly but it was not played and I mean
okay black does not have to take the
repetition black can are happening 26
play King age 8 but here white also I
think should be able to hold the draw
with e 5 yeah if black Marge's the pawn
white can come back to be one or c2 and
the black king is just too weak here
from Black team play for an advantage if
he tries to support the porn or at
London the Queen and how can you support
the porn actually like this let's say
yeah wyd returns and now gets attacked
going you cannot clap play for win here
with this kind of thing check check
check yeah you're running into the big
problems the move Queen g6 would have
been an invitation for a former draw
first of all and wouldn't have risked
anything but Carson's not doing that he
plays Quincy 6 it seems that he still is
in this full attack mode there's a super
aggressive attitude that he has played
the whole game with from like move 20 on
or something of 19 a very very tense
situation now
the eighth saw a pencil he is very
dangerous but blacks Kings also
extremely exposed however what you have
to say is I don't think that the risk is
it's like enormous because you should
almost always have some kind of
Perpetual against the black king of
things your things fail yeah queen d 8 x
ki can again a good move yeah
centralizing the Queen and f5 tried to
bust everything open a three and takes
very very logical stuff King g7 let's
also a good movie gets the King a little
bit more secure there on the on the 7th
rank yeah if a two white has this thing
and will be much better here after
winning the airport so keen to gtown
yeah and again interesting moment now
white can't play various things Queen B
5 that also was an option instead of
Queen to c6 and he played e7 however and
it is possible that he underestimated
something here that Carden
underestimated something usually I mean
usually kayaking the attitude in this
match is to really play safety first if
you have a draw let's say rather take
the draw than risk anything and maybe
cousin just expected him to check on you
for which would have been a draw
ultimately after takes jack's key
plundering stuff grid a set of course
King g6 Green a three and now let's draw
yeah but that was not playback and he
plays a move 93 and give him credit
that's a very strong black is not going
to just take the pawn on e4 but rather
intense to put the night only five on
five the night is very reliably blocking
the
on and making this bishop on g2 a bitty
pretty bad piece and black still has
that huge a pawn a really good really
good idea black is risking basically
nothing with this and the icons are not
played the move Queen term a five which
is probably a step in the wrong
direction here a move was pointed out
during the broadcast v5 and I like this
move a lot yeah if you check this now a
little bit it makes perfect sense if
black takes it with the Queen it's not a
good idea this is getting lost and you
probably want to take the pawn it's not
a good idea to let it exists so 90s and
now just to move Bishop to g5 this is an
extremely safe situation for wide now
because the bishop is not incarcerated
on g2 and it covers all important a2
square so that the pawn cannot promote
this would have been a very safe choice
actually but he did not do that you
played Queen to a5 may be overlooking or
under estimating the next move Quincy
five so again a good move back and puts
pressure on cards he has to make a
decision now what to do he played Queen
a six which is correct and now Knight to
e5 as I said this is a real rock of a pc
on if I'm very very nice Black is a pawn
down here but if anybody can do
something it's him an important point is
that night is getting close to the king
and the night often single-handedly can
defend the king this is a key concept in
this tradition yeah and here and we come
to the absolutely decisive moment of the
game
if you if you give this to a computer it
will be very much unimpressed with
everything and say you know this is just
a draw and it is a goal after glad to be
seven and i can probably not prove that
to you and it's probably also besides
the point the point is that by now White
has to be extremely precise to hold this
draw and counseling after just three or
four minutes played the move Queen to e6
and this is maybe maybe the move that
decides this this this event it's really
possible because now the Challenger
finds a great solution place the most h5
huh and it's really not that easy I mean
it's for those guys maybe it is but it
is really a good move it has a couple of
ideas the pawn looked at the g4 square
so that after potential age form and why
this is what Carly played the night can
come to g4 first of all the second more
important point is that in many cases
night to g6 and keon h6 is a perfectly
safe situation for the king yeah we
should look at maybe a concrete line to
illustrate let's say white goes back
which shows that Queenie 6 Wilson yeah
and let's say he goes back and black
tries to promote in a situation like
this track note how safe the black king
is if white tries to somehow get near
the Kenya there are no checks all those
checks are covered and this file is also
was directed covered by the night a
fantastic defensive situation here for
black and in the in in fact he cannot
prevent Queen B 2 a2 a1 black gets an
additional Queen yeah that was missed by
by the world champion that black
put up this kind of defensive idea or
maybe what he missed was in the actual
game continuation that's also possible
and i played age four and as we said and
white is out of moves it's the hideous
out of most so h 4 and now imported is
to make to make it to play the right
move water there are too tempting moves
the check and a true if black checks
first king edge shreed is actually
playable yeah now if black tries to get
this attacking mechanism and then this
is a perpetual track it's just a check
relatively simple perpetual so a2 first
is the key by threatening this white is
basically forced to take the pawn and
thousand did not take the pawn he
resigned at this point but we should
have a look if he takes it then i'd
check and now the key move 22 g 1 and
this is really awkward now queen h2 is
the mating threat and the other big
threat is not f2 and the crazy thing is
that there's absolutely there no checks
currently now queen a7 is covered why I
can check here but after King g6 there
is no check there's no check here this
is covered by the Queen and white has no
defensive move Knight an F to winning
the queen or twin edge to mate you
cannot cover both of them so that's the
first decisive game in this match the
Challenger takes the lead and i have to
say looking at the game yeah very
deservedly so he defended very very
young toad blood type O blood layin in
most of the game he had this miss of
course here within this situation where
Queen a4 was immediately ending it but
he played 23 but everybody makes
mistakes hear both sides made a mistake
c5 didn't objectively work and
their reputation also was missed but
this is time trouble and with two
minutes on the clock all kinds of things
happen so I think a good defensive job
are kayaking and very nice how we
capitalized at the end in this position
9325 this is very strong play very
strong play on the other hand we have to
look at what car did in this game it
really felt like it did not feel like a
game to me where we look at an even
match score it really looked like a game
like the final game that the world champ
you had to win or go home basically and
we're a loss and a draw is doesn't
matter maybe we need to win at all costs
it looked like that with many many
decisions are like f 4 h3 this is not
overdoing it maybe but it is risky it is
a very risky proposition from the get-go
and then continuously not going for
draws they were like yeah yet this draw
on it's not clear that it would end in a
draw but 26 is clearly safer than Quincy
succeed he kind of yeah he'd we put oil
into this fire or over and over and at
the end got burned by it this sometimes
happens to Carlton it's not a new thing
I mean he sometimes has tournaments
where that happens but it never happened
in a world championship match but okay
he only he only had played those two
matches against honor and I think this
is he a different kind of kind of
contest kayaking is really am yeah
making a real effort to make it
difficult card to win games he's not
risking anything much but he simply um
yeah defense so accurately that it's
used to yeah frustrate Carlton to no end
so that he somehow came to the
conclusion that you should play
extremely aggressively in this game in
it backfires quite hope this tip so he's
now behind the point was just formed
against to go
we will definitely see some exciting
games now they will know there's well
there won't be a dolt draw not a single
one and I think this is some real stern
test now for cars and you see a real
champion have one of the greatest
players ever or not yeah if you just do
this to match now without any fight then
okay you can't come back whatever yeah
he's young but yeah if he comes back and
still managed to win this wind is in a
situation where it's clearly not in its
best form and would be great but we'll
see what happens next game kayaking has
white would be very interesting to see
the the opening of that i would expect
kayaking to play you for again this is
just a safer move and yeah i mean karen
wants to play for drawers now from a
position of very very being very very
solid here just waiting for cars and to
do something and probably what cousin
should do is not to play in such an
ultra aggressive fashion but I mean it's
difficult obviously very difficult
situation I'm not sure what what the
odds are currently but it will be
interesting to see what the what the
odds are on a kayak in victory or or
China or whatever it's really really
interesting to see um ok I hope you
enjoyed the coverage here I'm very much
looking forward to the rest of the match
now it will be a very thrilling to see
what so what's happening in those final
four games thanks a lot for watching